Що означатиме проголошення
незалежності Каталонії,
окрім патріотичних святкувань на вулицях
Барселони, Жирони та Таррагони?
Навіть якщо Іспанія погодиться
на відокремлення краю,
це все одно потягне за собою низку непростих
та відверто неприємних наслідків.
Розлучення з Іспанією означатиме автоматичний вихід
з ООН, ЄС, НАТО, СОТ
та десятків інших міжнародних організацій.
Каталонії доведеться заново проходити процес вступу.
У випадку ЄС це може тривати десятиліттями,
тим більше вето навіть однієї країни-члена
може заблокувати весь процес -
а Іспанія вже заявила, що буде проти.
Звучить не дуже загрозливо, але на практиці
це означатиме втрату практично усіх прав і переваг,
якими користуються європейці.
Припиниться вільний рух товарів,
послуг, капіталу та людей,
завдяки якому зріс рівень життя в усіх країнах-членах ЄС.
Малий і середній бізнес втратять європейські субсидії.
Каталонці не зможуть легко найматися на роботу
в інших країнах Євросоюзу, а їхні діти
- навчатися в країнах ЄС на загальних підставах.
А візи до шенгенської зони стануть реальністю.
Бізнес вже почав переносити свої
штаб-квартири з Барселони до Мадрида.
Без ЄС каталонці втратять доступ на ринок 28 країн,
в яких мешкають понад 500 мільйонів людей.
А мита на каталонські товари суттєво знизять їхню
конкурентоспроможність, порівняно з європейськими.
І поки Каталонія знову не стане членом СОТ,
мита будуть максимальними.
Поява кордонів неминуче призведе до зниження товарообігу.
Усе це обвалить ВВП краю щонайменше на 25%.
Пенсії, зарплати та соціальна допомога скоротяться,
а товари й послуги подорожчають.
Останнє вплине ще й на кількість туристів.
На тлі цих проблем, вихід з зони євро стане
лише однією з неприємностей.
Каталонські банки більше не зможуть звертатися по допомогу
та за ліквідністю до Європейського центробанку.
А вона знадобиться, бо регіону
доведеться обслуговувати
п'яту частину спільного іспанського державного боргу.
Ідеться про десятки мільярдів євро на рік, які досі
Барселона й Мадрид виплачували спільно.
Неминучим є, схоже, і запровадження власної валюти.
Це вкрай незручно, адже головний ринок експорту -
ЄС - використовує євро.
Незалежність Каталонії означатиме не лише
друк нових паспортів, але й організацію власних
збройних сил,
прикордонної служби та інших силових відомств.
Ймовірно, за рахунок нових податків.
Проте питання й у безпеці, для якої важливі
співпраця та обмін інформацією між
правоохоронцями на рівні як Іспанії, так і ЄС.
Саме брак співпраці каталонських та іспанських
силовиків називали однією з передумов
нещодавнього теракту в Барселоні, коли загинули
13 людей і понад сто отримали поранення.
І останнє: фубольний клуб "Барселона"
більше не гратиме в іспанській футбольній лізі.